- Hi, this is Sal Khan,
founder of the Khan Academy.
I just wanted to announce our
second annual Talent Search.
As you may know, Khan Academy,
we're a not-for-profit
with a mission of a free
world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
And part of that is creating the content
that can reach students from Kindergarten
all the way through early college
in all of the core academic subjects.
That content is videos,
it's articles and exercises.
And the reason why we do the Talent Search
is we're looking for folks who can really
connect with students on those subjects.
And so this year we're doing
the talent search again,
and we're especially looking
at core academic subjects
that aren't on Khan Academy already
or where Khan Academy
does not already have
a significant offering.
I encourage you to go to
the Talent Search website
to get a little bit more detail there.
You know, this is a really
exciting thing for us.
There are going to be
prizes for the finalists,
but more importantly it's
a way for us to foster
more people getting involved
with content creation
which I think all of you will enjoy
and a way for us to discover new talent.
Last year, out of the
finalists, two have actually
had content creation
contracts with Khan Academy
including Grant and David.
- Hi everyone, my name is Grant Sanderson.
I was one of the Talent
Search winners from last year.
I now make multi-variable calculus videos
and some other content for Khan Academy.
And I just have to say,
as someone who cares
about reaching students
and who cares about
addressing needs like that,
I can't imagine a better
place to be than here.
And that's not just because
you can reach a lot of people,
but what the Khan Academy
folk around here care about
is just genuinely helping students.
- So I am the Grammar
Fellow at Khan Academy.
I am very passionate about grammar.
And I'm curious to know
what you're excited about.
What are your big passions?
What do you love to think about?
What do you love to tell people about?
What do people like learning from you?
Is it macroeconomics?
Is it business theory?
Is it psychology?
Whatever it is,
whatever your passion is,
put it into a video and send it to us.
- So please make your videos,
have fun with them,
think about how you can
connect with the world,
and send us your
submissions by August 1st.